tout commence en janvier 1816 dans les
champs du laboureur beauceron thomas
martin il est occupé à ces travaux
agricoles et soudain personnage arrive
il ne connaît pas il est étrange il est
vêtu d'une longue redingote blonde d'un
chapeau haut de forme et lui tient un
langage bizarre il lui dit tu dois aller
voir le roi pour lui dire que le tout
court à sa perte
puis le personnage s'évanouit d'un seul
coup cette vision n'est que la première
d'une longue série avec le même message
il faut aller avertir le roi de grands
malheurs qui frapperont la france
l'archange raphaël on va savoir assez
vite puisqu'il va dire je suis
l'archange raphaël fait des apparitions
y compris là dans ces banques l'eau et
martin à partir de ce moment là est
persuadé qu'il s'agit d'un messager
divin
s'ils passent d'abord pour déranger
thomas martin inquiète les autorités qui
le reçoivent à chartres puis paris pour
savoir qui il est un illuminé un
comploteur ou un vrai prophète s'il ne
convainc pas le ministre de la police
qui l'enferment dans un asile d'aliénés
d'autres personnes de l'entourage du roi
croit en ses visions
au point que louis xviii accepte de le
rencontrer en avril 1816 et louis xviii
ne peut pas faire autrement que de le
recevoir parce que sinon on ne
comprendrait pas que
roy ne reçoivent pas un envoyé du ciel
donc il est sceptique mais ils
l'écoutent quand même avec attention et
il semble que certaines révélations vont
émouvoir le roi 14 ans plus tard le
frère et successeur de louis xviii
charles 10 ne sais pas ce qu'il doit
faire face à la révolution de juillet
1830 et lui se souvient de martin il
envoie des personnages un général
général de l'ars jacquelin en pleine
nuit dans la nuit du 31 juillet au 1er
août 1830 consulter martin pour savoir
s'il doit abdiquer ou non et donc martin
qui hélas eu devant sa maison avec sa
lanterne en chemise dit non il en est
pas question les bourbons c'est fini ni
charlot disent ni ses enfants ne
règneront désormais charles 10 abdique
alors mais les illuminations de martin
en contrarie plus d'un au point qu'il
est assassiné en 1834 le mystère règne
toujours sur l'identité de son meurtrier
[Musique]